proud
your mama and this whole family your
mama's so proud of you
and for what you have become and we know
god gonna keep doing great things in
your life
and you just live honey and be happy and
accept whatever you bring your way
and just keep going and we just want you
to know
that was a great moment on saturday it's
a shame it happened on a weekend where
we couldn't all really appreciate it the
way we should have in real time but
when the texans announced the desean
watson contract they had
a press conference but it was kind of
like the old show this is your life and
it's a really old show chris you
probably don't know what it is but
it was like dabo sweeney shows up and
justin verlander shows up and then his
family shows up
and he didn't know any of it was gonna
happen so he was overwhelmed by the
moment it was really neat to see
but the occasion a very positive one for
deshaun watson second contract
a huge deal a four-year extension
remember he had wanted
three he got four he's under contract
for six years
six fewer than patrick mahomes and
i you know you know i it's
i i it's hard to to say that a half
billion dollar deal isn't as good as it
could have been but the desean watson
contract compares
very favorably over the first four years
to the patrick holmes deal
and then watson will only be under
contract for two more years and and my
homes be under contract for eight more
years after that yeah no it's a great
contract definitely i mean you know
yeah he probably took that extra year
because it took a little pressure off
the organization helps the team that way
uh but they paid him you know deservedly
so
they're paying him for what he's done
and what he's about to do this is a guy
that's just like
just starting to reach the the pinnacle
of who he is as a football player
plus he is like like a patrick mahomes
no doubt the guy you want to be the face
of your franchise
the guy that you want to be the leader
in your locker room
i mean they just don't make them any
nicer than a guy like deshawn watson i
mean he truly is the kind of guy where
you'd like
your your daughter brings him home and
hey i'm gonna marry you're like what
really is good i mean he's a perfect
human being from what i've seen being
around him
you know so that is just all awesome and
i love that
and of course he has been he's the face
of the texans right now jj watt era is
done it's desean watson and they're
going to ride this wave as long as they
can
39 million per year in new money under
the contract it puts him ahead of
russell wilson by four million per year
as it relates to new money
six million per year behind mahomes but
again mahomes had to sign a 12-year
contract
to get to 45 million per year desean
watson only had to sign
a six-year contract to make that happen
but when you look
at the comparison watson mahomes on
signing bonus yeah
watson did better first year payout
watson did better
second year payout watson did better
third year payout
up to four years through the first four
years watson makes more like by seven
million dollars than mahomes over the
first four years of his contract
now i will say this and i don't want to
take any way anything away from deshaun
watson's contract
but even though his contract compares
favorably
in the early years to mahomes there are
other contracts
that compare favorably to watson's ryan
tanhill for example
on a four-year deal with the titans
making 118 million eight million more
than watson's gonna make over the next
four
years and then tannehill free to go
anywhere he wants after that
so uh that and look again i i hate
number one i love patrick mahomes and
number two it's his right to sign
whatever contract he wants
and number three he's going to be well
taken care of and he had different
objectives and agendas than a guy who
wants every last penny right
but when when when watson's contract you
can compare it to my homes and say boy
watson got a better deal
and then there's all these other deals
you can look at and say wow those are
better too
it does become a little bit glaring
definitely especially when people around
the league are constantly buzzing about
it yeah no you i mean you're right
there's there's no denying it
you know there's no like there's no way
to sit here and go oh no
really but you're missing this the homes
deal has this and that it's really
better than you think no
you know it's it's not all that
impressive you're right at face value
when you look at
you know 10 years and half a billion
dollars and all that it's hey that's
great
uh but that means nothing in this day
and age in the nfl but i do think with
mahomes and the circumstances
he was in are a little different than
some of these other people
you know they had of course they won a
super bowl
he wants to keep that together so that
kind of hurts a guy like patrick mahomes
you can go one of two ways there you can
go wait we won the super bowl because of
me
and give me every freaking dollar you
got or you can go
wait we have a pretty good thing going
here the team's pretty good i'll take a
little less because i want to keep tyree
kill
and hey we gotta sign chris jones and
all those things so there was some
pieces in place there where
yeah money was already getting thrown
around the kansas city chiefs player and
he knew
more money had to be spread out a little
bit and he took one for the team that
way it is glaring there's no doubt about
it but
i don't think it's anything um different
than what we've seen from patrick
mahomes to this point of his career
kind of just a humble approach he's
happy with what he's getting
and he wants a team around him so he can
try to this this quest to be the
greatest of all time
and i think what will happen is deshaun
watson will get another new contract
four years from now and that may be the
spark that gets the chance
to go right the mahomes deal you know
the chiefs have no obligation to do it
but i think by then they'll be happy to
do it
the world will be different the cap will
be different the market will have
changed
and it will be glaring i think within
four years when you see mahomes at 45
and there's going to be other guys at 50
or more and you're going to say wait a
minute no those guys are patrick mahomes
that's right now
here's what's odd about the desean
watson situation 2017 while patrick
mahomes is on the bench behind alex
smith
watson is playing and watson is taking
the nfl by storm and watson is in the
mvp conversation as a rookie he tears
the acl in practice non-contact in early
november he told us at the super bowl
that year
he thinks he did it against the seahawks
a few days earlier remember it was that
game against the seahawks that had
richard sherman seek him out and say
you're great played the best of any
quarterback that we've ever faced and
they had faced tom brady multiple
occasions
so watson goes from being the flavor of
the year in 2017
and i feel like he's been fighting
against the headwind ever since then
to get that same respect 2018 it's
mahomes
2019 it's lamar jackson and
deshawn why even though i mean you and i
regard him
among the top quarterbacks in the nfl
yeah i feel like he is fighting and
scratching and clawing to get any
attention
in comparison to these other guys in his
conference and a lot of it has to do
with the fact that he doesn't have the
team around him i agree that those guys
do
agreed you know yeah you know we how
many times last year did we talk about
yeah
it's you know hopkins yeah awesome right
you got
you know uh will fuller oh he can never
play so oh it's back to i gotta throw to
hopkins every damn play
and gotta do that you know even kenny
stills had moments of being injured last
year so
there hasn't been great support and
let's not forget
at the very least as compared to mahomes
and lamar jackson
you know until and really i think this
will be the best one he's had so far
going forward
his offensive line has been crap i mean
crap last year it was a little bit
better the first two years of his career
i mean you could argue it was like top
five worst pass protecting offensive
lines in all of football
and yet they were still winning games
and in the playoffs and those things
because of deshawn watson
so the leadership the talent the
continuing work ethic
everything like that for me yeah i mean
i expect mahomes to be number one for a
long time
you know right now like my quarterback
rankings right i had russell two
aaron rodgers three desean watson four i
expect here in the next year to two that
it becomes mahomes and watson one and
two
for a long period of time and then it's
just gonna be who challenges that
to maybe get into a year where i'm
number two or i'm number three whatever
that may be
but i really look at these two as kind
of like the big future stars of football
yeah i agree with you and i think that
that if they can get that
better team around him and this may be
the year with david johnson there if he
has a rebirth with the receivers
who aren't deandre hopkins so deshaun
watson doesn't hold the ball maybe as
long as he used to because he's waiting
for hopkins to come open
the defense needs to take a step up but
you know
it's i i had this thought while we were
talking about it you put deshaun watson
on the ravens
do the ravens miss a beat you put
deshawn watson on the chiefs
are the chief still one of the best
teams in the nfl moving these guys
are the team's still the same right
that's my point yeah i think that's it's
a very fair question
you know yeah i don't know if they would
really miss a whole lot a beat either
way like if deshawn watson goes to the
baltimore ravens
yeah they're not going to be as good at
running with the quarterback and that
but they're going to get a boost in the
pass game from the quarterback
you know and then you could probably say
the opposite with kansas city yeah he
goes to kansas city they're still going
to be awesome is he going to make his
amazing throws as my homes all the time
no but he's still gonna make you know a
lot more a lot of amazing ones
and have more of a threat of a scramble
and a runner than mahomes is
so you know that that to me yes mahomes
the one thing as great as he is and
listen he's as talent as i've ever seen
he's got a great support system around
him
and he's got a great pass protection and
a good play caller the stars aligned for
my homes for us to
really you know see his talents come to
the surface because the support systems
around him
i'm not sure we've seen the best of
desean watson yet
because of the the factors we've already
mentioned like you've said and i think
this year we have a chance to finally
really see it
with a a true wide receiving core and an
offensive line that i think is going to
be the best he's played at in his career
to where i go oh he could do some
special things this year
but i'm also going to go back to that
gladiator concept
the argue not entertained notion right
when we compared russell wilson and
patrick mahomes with wilson it happens
so fast you don't appreciate it
with mahomes there's that that hair
on fire quality that makes you sit on
the edge of your seat where
he does that thing that we say holy crap
i mean the end result
25-yard gain but it looks a lot more
intriguing and exciting
than the normal 25-yard gain would and i
think mahomes benefits from that and
look he's it doesn't take anything away
from his ability but there is
more of a of an inherent showmanship not
that he's doing it to be showy it's just
his game right
but it makes it more exciting to watch
patrick holmes and on desean watson
running the ball yeah i mean he may not
be as large
as strong and as fast as lamar jackson
but
but he's an extremely effective ball
carrier because he's got
i think better than any other
quarterback an inherent sense of the
movement of his body in relation to
everyone else's
he knows where the opening is and he
goes there and he knows he's almost like
what aaron rodgers does
just run to where the other guys aren't
yeah right and go out of bounds and
slide
he was better with that last year and
protecting himself too right yeah
and and i remember when he had that long
touchdown run as a rookie against
the bengals it's like you know he didn't
turn on the jets
but he was always able to navigate the
other bodies out there
to keep working his way through to open
spaces so i think he could be a very
effective runner if you used him
aggressively as a runner but i think
part of the reason you don't you look at
him and you say where's the rest of him
yeah yeah i mean
when we've met him right i mean he's not
he's not
thick right he he and he looks like a
guy who's not going to be able to take
that pound
yeah no you're right i mean he's well
you know what what is the sean watson
if you look him up there is he six two
and change maybe six
three on the dot you know i'm going to
say 215
maybe right around 220 or something like
that
but he is he's just he's ace yeah go
ahead he's listed at
six two two sixteen yeah that's what
means which means he's six
one two oh five well yeah i i would say
i would say the heights probably pretty
accurate because the nfl right now at
the combine they are there on you
so i would imagine that there but the
weight thing
yeah i bet you he's had moments of being
208
207 things like that he's a special
player and you're right
he's so elusive and forget the running
and everything like that it's his
ability to make plays behind the line of
scrimmage too like we saw what was at
the raiders game last year when he got
kicked in the face
and still stayed up and throws a
touchdown pass you know
he's cool and calm under pressure all
the time
and got his first playoff win last year
was down 16 to nothing brought him back
and you could say what you want about
the loss in kansas city listen his team
scored 31 points
you know he he can't play defense too so
hey
hopefully their offense will be better
this year to where maybe if they have to
do that again they can score more
but he certainly like didn't melt away
under the pressure last year where we're
coming away from the season with deshaun
watson going like
i don't know he's got a few more
questions for me to answer
there are zero questions for him to
answer for me star
awesome gonna be here for a long time
you know other nuances of the game he
can continue to prove
of course but nothing i look at to go
off he doesn't do that
you know he'll never make that next step
or go to the next level as a quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports